- Hello, and welcome to "Ed
Talks with Khan Academy."
I am excited today to
talk with Kara Bobroff,
who is the founder of the Native
American Community Academy
and NACA Inspired Schools.
We're gonna talk about
culture in education broadly
and the education of Native
American students in particular,
so looking forward to that.
Before we get started, a couple of notes.
A reminder that Khan Academy
is a nonprofit organization,
and we are able to do our work
thanks to the generous
donations from people like you.
If you go to khanacademy.org/donate,
you will see and have the
opportunity to be able to donate
to help us continue our mission.
Similarly, we wanna thank
some of our supporters
who really stepped up
during the COVID crisis
to help us with our work,
and that includes Bank of
America, AT&T, Google.org,
Novartis, Fastly, and General Motors.
Reminder, if you want
to hear this talk again
or if you have missed
some and wanna catch up,
you can get audio versions of these talks
at the "Homeroom with Sal" podcast,
available wherever you get your podcasts.
So with that, let me welcome Kara Bobroff.
It's nice to have you.
- It's nice to be here.
I'm super excited for our conversation,
and I'm really looking forward to it.
- Great, so I like to
start off asking people,
how did you get to where you are today?
What was, tell us a
little bit about your path
to starting these schools and this network
and all the work you do.
- Yeah, thank you, Kristen, for that.
It's a interesting story
of like two or three
different dynamics of a journey,
both personal, professional,
and then also like kind of a calling
or what needed to happen
within our community.
So I'm Navajo and Lakota.
I'm gonna introduce myself in that way.
(Kara speaking in foreign language)
So on my mother's side,
biological mother's side,
I am Navajo, and our family's
from a community in New Mexico
called Ramah, which is not
contiguous with Navajo Nation
but are Navajo Nation.
And on that side, we're the Salt Clan,
and that's how we identify.
So we recognize our relatives,
so if any relatives out there today
that are also Salt Clan and
Navajo just wanted to say,
you know, open up kind of
conversation on that level,
just to say, that's an
important relationship.
The second part is
Lakota, and on that side,
my biological father was
from Pine Ridge area,
and so near Pine Ridge and Rosebud.
I grew up in Albuquerque, New Mexico,
and basically my parents
were both educators.
My mom was a middle school
teacher her entire life.
My father was a teacher,
assistant principal, principal,
became a systems leader as
well of our school district,
but not really knowing I
was gonna become a teacher.
So really had a important aspect
of something that happened
when I was about 19 years old.
I served as a mental health worker
in a residential treatment center,
and that was the first time
I started to work with youth
who were six years, seven years,
eight years younger than I
who were going in and
out of various systems,
from foster care to, you
know, the psychiatric hospital
to home for all sorts of reasons.
And I think that really
set in stone for me
that those students had
been, or children had been
through more in their life
than I would ever have to really endure
and kinda like really
drew me into education,
although my family's
influence had for sure.
Became a special education
teacher at the school I went to,
started to see all the good things
about being a teacher
and also started to see
some inequities around who had access
to what kind of courses and
how that was determined,
predetermined for a lotta kids
and reflected back on my own experience
and saw that that was probably
true when I was there.
Just like there was a group of us,
and 1/3 of us went to one classroom,
1/3 of us went to another,
and 1/3 of us went to another.
And I'm not really sure why,
but then we would kind of like reconnect.
So that was interesting to experience.
Served as assistant
principal at the school
my older siblings went to,
which freaked them out. (laughs)
(Kristen laughs)
They'd come in and like,
"How can you be like
the assistant principal
where we went to school?"
My journey took me to the Bay Area,
and I served as a dean of
students in Marin County
in school, Miller Creek Middle School,
and that was the first time
I started to see a couple things.
One, that school provided
so many opportunities
for their students and families
and was really responsive
to their community.
It wasn't a question of which
college kids would go to.
It was a question of like what college,
I mean, if they would go to college,
it was a question of like
which college they would go to,
which was very different,
much more responsive
socially and emotionally to the students.
However, there was a lack of diversity.
So also from an equity standpoint,
just kinda saw like the difference
between what students
and teachers had there
as a public school than what
I kind of experienced myself
and how schools were
operated at that time.
Also, during that time back home,
I was there for four years,
there was a conversation around
Native American education
and a need for Native American
magnet or charter school,
and that's probably the first
time I heard about that,
and I always thought, "That'd
be a cool place to work
when I moved back home." (laughs)
However, you know, I think
that that was kind of grounded
in the fact that many of our elders
and those who'd come
before in a urban setting,
you know, always had a
longing to do something more
for Native youth in
Albuquerque specifically,
knowing that that district
serves about 80,000 kids,
6 to 7,000 self-identify as Native.
And in like that time to now,
when we look at the census,
that population of urban
Indigenous families
has increased not only in Albuquerque
but across the United States.
So just kind of got an interest in that.
Would go back and forth
for different, you know,
times just having that conversation,
and nothing really kinda came to.
My journey to Shiprock, New Mexico,
where I was served as a principal
at Newcomb Middle School,
which was like the best school on Earth
in the sense of like a place
I really felt connected.
I kinda thought, like I didn't
speak my language fluently,
so I didn't know if I
would be the best principal
for the community, but what
I found was a couple things.
One, that the strengths of
the students and families
and the cultural knowledge was so great
that it should be
incorporated into the school
as like how the students
in Marin had so many things
brought into their school, you
know, opportunities as well.
But there was a dialogue that was going on
that was really troublesome in the sense
that at that time, the
school board thought,
"Well, we shouldn't be
teaching Navajo language
'cause that inhibits
students' ability to read."
And if you think about
research in general,
or just like things
that we know to be true,
when you're bilingual,
trilingual, multilingual,
those are all major strengths.
There's a lot of bias to unpack,
a lot of institutionalized,
I would say deficit mindsets
around the students,
like, "Are these students
gonna go to college?"
And even like teachers that I
was becoming the principal of
would say to me, they'd, you know,
"The families here don't
necessarily value education,
and so why would we ask our students
whether they wanna go to college?"
And so I tried to like
remain calm and diplomatic,
at the same time, use data to
prove that that wasn't true,
which we did by kind of, you know,
engaging our parents in that conversation,
and found that like 98% of
the families want their kids
to go on to a two-to-four-year
college experience.
So just, that was a really tough situation
'cause there was a lot of opportunity.
The school was like fledgling
and almost went into like a
school improvement process
that would've put them at danger
of like being taken over
by the state at that time.
We were able to turn it around
and really started to think
about differentiation, more
involvement of student voice,
all those good things that
people would want their kids
to have in a school, and we saw progress.
So as well as like my own personal journey
around my own identity, growing
up not on the reservation
but in a city being, you know,
disconnected from my family
and then having to reconnect
was really a powerful thing
that I was experiencing.
But came back home, wanted to
follow up on the idea of NACA
and really started to engage
the community in that process.
So I would say it's a lot
of those different things.
And then also just, you
know, I would say my family
had a lot of like impact on
me, both like immediately,
and also some of my grandparents
who really like forged
the way around education
within their own communities, too.
- Wow, that is excellent.
So that kind of leads us right
into, tell us a little bit
about the Native American
Community Academy.
And if we went and visited, what would it,
what would we see, what
would it look like?
- So NACA is like synonymous with me
with the same like word as far as love.
Like, there is so much
like interconnectedness
and like relationships among students,
teachers, and families,
it's truly a community.
I think of NACA like an
essence of being like something
that was not in existence
that came into existence.
It just connected people together in ways
that grew an entire like web
of support for generations.
So it's our 16th year.
You would see students
learning inside and outside,
so like land-based learning
as well as learning
like in a traditional, I guess, classroom.
You would see students
on a college campus,
and you would also see
early learning taking place
in a elementary school,
access to four or five different languages
that they can take throughout the time
that they're at the school, Lakota, Zuni,
Navajo language, Keres, Tiwa, Tewa,
partnerships with community organizations,
access to school-based health centers,
students being able to not
only know like who they are
and where they come from
but being able to articulate
a vision they have
that's meaningful to them
based on their own worldview.
One of the foundational pieces of NACA
as we were putting the school together,
and like what I mean by that
is we literally went out
and talked to community
members over a period
of like a year and a half, two years
about, you know, what
is it that we wanna see
for Native American students?
And three things rang true.
One is that there would be both access
and like success going to college,
and that was based on a
lot of people's experience
about not having that
within their own education
and/or going to college and not succeeding
within the first year, for all
sorts of different reasons.
The second is that the
students would be secure
in their identity and understanding
like what is their identity,
not only as an Indigenous person,
but maybe somebody who's bicultural
and somebody who also has like a passion
in the area of the arts,
but being able to be
in connection with that
in a very real way is one major outcome.
And the last is that
students would be healthy,
and this is where the NACA Wellness Wheel,
it's on our website,
anybody can access it,
is foundational to the
start of the school.
We talked a lot about like what patterns
and like aspects of
Native American education
had not worked in the past,
and we talked about like some
of the things that we saw
as far as data and outcomes
for Native students.
But we wanted to start with
a strengths-based mindset,
and we selected the Wellness Wheel,
which is kind of based off of,
basically a lot of different
tribes think of like people
as being like whole individuals.
Like, you're not just coming to school
to access like one aspect of who you are.
You bring all of yourself.
So intellectually, how
are students, you know,
faring physically, like
your physical wellness,
as well as your social-emotional wellness
and your connection to your community
and overall spirituality,
and spirituality not being religiosity,
but realizing like, what are
those things that renew us?
What are those things that
we can help reflect upon?
So our students spend a lot of time
working with the Wellness Wheel
as well as other courses and classes.
95% of the student's day is grounded
in Indigenous perspectives,
meaning that we're bringing in either,
whether that's authors or
whether that's like knowledge
from elders or knowledge
from our content teachers
in their languages or Indigenous
science and understanding,
you know, ecological
aspects of different things
that have taken place.
But those things are integrated
into how students are,
how and what students are learning
and how being really, really
important, I think, too.
So those are all the
things that you would see.
I can talk about NACA for several hours,
but I always feel like,
like when I think of like
our students are learning
things that may be, you
know, hard to learn.
So I think of like kids
in the middle school
who are understanding
like the role of education
in Native communities around
boarding schools, right?
And so they rock, or they experience
a lot of emotion around that.
They're doing an
intergenerational interview
with their grandmother who
went to the boarding school
who's reflecting back to
them, "I'm glad you're at NACA
and have access to language
and culture, I didn't,"
you know, all of those like
really powerful things.
They take that interview and
transcribe it into an actual,
you know, written piece, use that piece
in the like student demonstration
where they're like presenting
that back to their community.
And then proactively as an entire class,
they decide to do something
that's much more positive
and productive as to like not get caught
into the negativity or the victimization
of like our history, but
really being more, I guess,
like a visionary in the
sense of like they have
like the ability to
really empower themselves,
to think about what it is
they wanna see different.
So a lot of different aspects of that,
and we really hope that NACA's a place
where our students can not
only explore their identity
but act upon it in ways that makes sense,
like whether that's slam poetry.
It could be, you know, a
service-oriented project could be,
you know, anything that
really resonates with them.
Yeah, so that's just a
little bit about NACA,
but it's pretty amazing place.
- Yeah, thanks for sharing all of that.
It definitely, I have so
many questions. (laughs)
And I know we wanna talk
about the network piece, too.
But one of the things that I
know I see in learning research
is that when students
feel like they belong
and have that feeling of belongingness,
we see better learning outcomes as well,
and it sounds like that that,
that building in that culture, it then,
it seems related to that
research of where things are.
So do you see that relationship
between, for instance,
the identity and that end
academic achievement as well?
- Yeah, I would say the
belonging and connectedness,
of the essence of community
of our school is huge.
I think of like a story
of one of our students.
Her mom shared this with me,
but she came to NACA, and
for the first semester
at least, six months, was really quiet,
didn't really share too much,
but was always participating
and like did what she needed to do,
and like, you know, was a
really cool kid and just like,
but didn't really like articulate a lot
and shares too much with her peers
or in the classroom setting.
And then she kinda turned a corner,
and I remember her mom came
back and said, you know,
like, "My daughter, the
entire time she was in school
up until the time she came,
didn't talk in school,
and now I can't get her to stop talking,"
like total transformation
in the sense of like now
she's like leading classroom discussions,
like, she's leading projects,
she's like involved in like different
kind of extracurricular activities.
And so I feel like that we,
I know from my own personal experience,
when you're in a setting
that sees who you are,
is reflected in what you're learning,
values who that is, who
you are, and what that is,
that you open up and you're
able to not have to navigate
like the worry about like, "How
are people's perceiving me"
and "Are they going to
make fun of the fact
that I have to go to a
ceremony for a few days
with my family and come back,"
or that there's a song
that's a traditional song
that we want to share.
So all of those things are
some of the points of strength,
and it becomes like just that's
how the school is, right?
It's not, and this is how our
community has been operating
since time immemorial,
let alone the fact that,
you know, kids can be
leading in that space.
So that's like one small story.
You know, I do remember the
worst kind of situation of that
is like when you're in a school setting
where that's not valued
and it's actually like
you experience some
sort of microaggression
and/or like racial, you
know, slur of some sort,
and then like shuts kids
down really, really quickly.
So we do see that.
I would say that we also see
like some of the students who are involved
in like learning their language,
it gives them a bigger
insight into their history
as well as their identity,
and that helps set them
up for later success.
Some of our alumni who
went to different schools
like ranging from Ivy to
small liberal arts schools,
community colleges, tribal colleges,
all kinda report back like,
"Well, like these are the teachers
who had the biggest impact on us,"
which were largely the teachers who had
most of that cultural
knowledge and connectedness.
And also they were like inspired.
Like, "When, we went this," you know,
"I went to so-and-so school,
I started this like effort
around Native American students,
but also all of the
other students of color
were going through an identity crisis,
and they were having a really hard time
and struggling in a different setting,
and I didn't really go through that."
Like, "I felt super grounded in who I was.
A lot of the content we had
already like engaged with,
and so I felt better
prepared in that sense."
So I think that definitely
the belonging is a huge piece
and also understanding your identity.
And also we're talking about generations
of folks who've been separated,
when you think about what boarding schools
did to our communities
and just not having that
be the perspective of
education that most students
across the country engage with.
- Can you give a little bit
of that history for folks
that aren't familiar of the
boarding schools and what that,
the results of that were?
- Yeah, yeah.
So there's like a quote
that talks about basically
like "killing the Indian
and saving the man,"
so this idea that both assimilation
and kind of direct causation of children
being removed from their
homes would be more beneficial
to Native American communities
across the United States.
And this was like back in the
1800s, and thinking about,
and also iterations of that
all the way through the time
that we are now in today.
So I think of it in a couple ways.
One, you know, pre-contact,
there wasn't any kind of interaction
between Native communities
and Westernized culture,
and there wasn't even an
institution of education.
We call that like Indigenous education.
Then we did have like the treaties
that were negotiated across the country.
I think of my tribe, you know,
the Navajo Nation in particular,
and one thing that
holds true in that sense
is that the way I was told was
that our leaders at the time
were forcibly removed
and all of our people
from one side of our state to the other
and imprisoned in an encampment.
In that encampment, in order to go back
after 2 1/2 years, they
had to negotiate a treaty.
Part of that treaty negotiation
was that the Navajo Nation
would take on one teacher for 25 kids
that would be provided by
the United States government.
And the leaders were having
this discussion in Navajo
with a Spanish interpreter to Spanish
and then Spanish to English
and English back to Spanish,
and so it was quite, you know,
something that was of great concern.
Otherwise, we would've been removed
to Oklahoma or potentially Florida.
So in order to go back
to where our four sacred mountains are,
they said, yes, but they asked like,
"What are the patterns
of this education system?
How does it work? How does it function?"
Before that, like learning was seamless
and within communities
and also within like the
origins of our seasons.
So that's one example.
As we move through, like as you get
into the '50s and '60s and '70s,
the resurgence of tribal
colleges as well as other schools
focused on language and
culture to self-determination,
and so you started to see schools
like now Rough Rock Demonstration Schools
and the Ramah day school
that were started to
bring language and culture
and community-based education
back into communities
versus having students have
to leave their community.
And now we're in a time where I feel like
there's such a movement
around Indigenous people
and also recognizing the importance
of culturally responsive education
as well as like what's being taught
that's really, really important.
And so it's important to
kids, first and foremost,
and I think that's what
makes our education better
and also helps them be more successful
in being able to do what they need to do
and knowing who they are and
understanding that history.
And also all students, I think,
need to understand that for sure.
- Yeah!
- But, yeah.
- And so that leads
to then the question, the idea,
all students need to understand this.
How do we take the things that
you've learned through NACA
and think about scaling where those are?
So I know one step was
the NACA Inspired Schools.
So tell me a little bit about that.
- Yeah, so like within the
first two years of NACA,
we were asked several times, like,
"Can we start a NACA in our community?"
So when people come to
visit, they're like,
"Oh my God, this is possible.
This is what people were writing about
in the '50s and '60s.
This is what our elders were saying
needs to be incorporated
back into school," right?
So we were like, "Yes,
but it needs to come
from your community."
So we're like, "How do we do that?"
So we put together the NACA
Inspired Schools Network.
I worked with some folks to think about
like what that would look like.
Basically, we support fellows
who work with their
communities and engage them
in a similar process as we did it at NACA
is to come up with their own
mission and vision of a school
that makes sense for them
around Indigenous education.
So there's, let's see,
maybe five, six schools
in New Mexico right now,
some up in South Dakota
that are coming online,
Denver as well as another one down in Ute.
And so really it's just
like having a conversation
about if we were to build
something for our children
and Native American kids
like wherever that may be,
what would that look like?
What would we want to accomplish,
and how would we go about that?
So some schools are really heavily focused
on language and culture.
Some are really, maybe
a dual-language model.
Some are focused on immersion.
All have like the components
of holistic wellness,
culture, and Indigenous perspectives.
Some are really, really
focused on land-based learning.
Others are doing like internships,
different things like
that, it just depends.
But that's one way we started to share it.
The other is we created
an Indigenous Knowledge Management Hub,
which is open to anybody to
find like what our teachers
have created and to contribute
and/or just utilize those
types of lessons K through 12.
I feel like so much of this
is like equally important
to students that are in a traditional,
maybe comprehensive like,
you know, elementary school,
middle school, or high
school to understand
like not only the content
that we have provided,
but also just being able
to understand the history
of the United States and like
the role that Native people
have played and continue to.
So those are some things that
we've done to help share.
- Can you say the name of that again,
that has all the lessons that?
- Oh, yeah, it's on the NACA
Inspired Schools' website.
It's called the Indigenous
Knowledge Management Hub,
which is probably not the most (laughs)-
- Inspiring name. (laughs)
- So if anybody out there
has like a suggestion
on like what to name that,
feel free to like send that back our away.
- Excellent, excellent, so you,
a couple of times had mentioned that,
and now I've forgotten
what you, what it's called,
but the land-based teaching.
- Yeah.
- Can you just tell us
a little bit about what that
is and what that looks like?
- Yeah, so when we first started NACA,
we started with a focus
on experiential education
as well as like a project
around healthy food
and Indigenous farming and gardening,
and so getting kids like that are involved
in actually working on the
land to do things that,
to center their learning.
So that was like the first
kind of iteration of that.
Now that has grown into a team at NACA
that started focusing on things
such as like water and water defenders
and understanding like what,
the importance of water
within our communities,
medicine, and like how
do we identify medicine
when we're out and about
in different areas,
whether that's in our home communities
or within the city or within
the mountains next to us,
as well as food and understanding
the importance of food
and healthy food, how food is grown,
how food systems work, and
how do they exist or not exist
within our communities as well.
And then also thinking
about just other ways
to blend learning around sciences,
whether that's through literature,
whether that's through math,
whether that's through
different content areas
that teachers can connect to,
like taking their students
out to the land to be able to do that.
So, you know, whether that's
a inquiry science project
or it's a, you know,
taking a group of students
to harvest pinon for that time
and understanding why the
significance culturally
and also the significance of
pinon within the community,
what that means, and then distribution,
and like, what does that mean as well?
So part of that, we
actually are now launching
Indigenous Farmers Hub, which
is building out a CSA model
to then like grow food and
be able to provide that food
back to our students and
families and community at large
where students are actively engaged
in understanding how do you
develop a healthy food system
and what does it mean to grow harvest food
and create like those opportunities
in Indigenous farming?
So that's an example,
but something I think
that also connects our students to land
and to other people within our community
who may not be a traditional teacher,
like in the sense of they
come up through a pipeline,
that might be through a university,
but there are those community members
who hold all this different knowledge
and like expertise that
they can learn from.
- Great.
So if you think about teachers
in maybe a traditional public
school and where those are
who want to do and bring more
of this into their classroom,
what advice do you have for them
about how to think about
making their classrooms
more culturally responsive?
- Yeah, I think knowing
your students and families
and starting there, and just, I mean,
and really getting to
build a relationship.
When I think about being
culturally responsive
or culturally and linguistically
responsive in education,
this is like something, you know,
I spent about 18, 20 months at the state
thinking about what
are the lessons learned
that we can share?
One of them is like really understanding,
like what's the historical context
of the community in which
you serve as a teacher,
whether you have to do that in isolation,
or you can do that as an entire school.
Two, engaging your community
and like what it is
they want to see for their children
and getting an understanding of that.
So it helps guide the
processes and protocols
and like outcomes that you're aiming for.
I also believe that we have to have
like open conversations and
courageous conversations,
and we never, ever wanna set up a student
to come into a classroom where they feel
like they don't belong.
So the sense of belonging
within a classroom setting
and/or a school setting is something
that is really, really important.
And opening up your curriculum
so that students can explore that
in a way that's healthy for them and safe,
and also that brings in
the different dimensions
of all the students that you serve.
So one of our parents reflected back to us
in our first year, like, "When
you said you were gonna serve
like 62 different tribes
and 13 different ethnicities
and be able to do that
through your curriculum,
I thought it was like,
like I wanted to see that.
And I also thought it
was incredibly ambitious,
and I had no idea how
you were gonna do that
with that many different
tribes and perspectives."
And so talked about like how our teachers
are able to facilitate like open-ended
kind of universal questions,
enduring understandings,
and essential questions
that lended themselves
to students being able to do that.
And when he, then in a
focus group came back
and told us, like, "My son
comes home and he tells me
not only did he share
about where he's from
and what he knows about
our family and our culture
and our background and
like what he was reading,
he also heard from like
the other, you know,
15 students in his cohort
about what it was that,
their family's experience."
So then it becomes like
just the way to be able
to share that without
any kinda hesitation.
And I think that, you know, students now
like really understand
their own identities
in ways that I don't believe many of us
ever had that opportunity in
school to be able to do that.
So creating real community
and being open-ended
in like how you're thinking about teaching
and also letting students lead
I think is like a good place to start.
- Yeah, I've heard that
community message from you
coming through loud and clear
that it really has to be,
everything is based on
understanding the community
that you're serving in
and where those are.
How do you, if you have new
teachers coming into the school,
how do you prepare them?
What kinds of training do they go through?
- Yeah, so a couple things, one, you know,
as we were growing the school every year,
we'd have like a new set
of teachers coming in
to try to do that.
A lot of it's just modeling,
so like when we started,
the first day of school
like was very different.
We started with a song from
one of our Navajo instructors
as well as a song from one
of our Lakota instructors.
And it was, we were outside in a circle
with families and
students at the same time,
really just acknowledging
like, this is very different,
but this is like, shouldn't
be different, right?
It should be the norm, and
it is now the norm, right?
So just like being able to have,
and I would always invite our new teachers
to those types of experiences
before they come on board
so that they're seeing
how maybe we close the end of one year out
and those significant
traditions that we have,
whether it was like, you know,
our ceremonies at the end
around student recognition
and graduation and what those look like,
whether it was like a
community kind of event
of some sort, too, whether
it was an annual powwow
or a feast day that we have in the fall.
But other than that, it's
like building in the time,
first of all.
It's like giving teachers
like three hours a week
to be able to have time with their teams,
having a mentor within the school
that understands the school culture,
core values, and what does that mean
when we talk about Indigenous
perspectives in education
if you're Native or non-Native,
and you're a teacher at the school,
as well as we created a
couple different things.
One is called Growing Educators
for Native American Communities
where we co-created
with a community college
a certification program that
uses the NACA framework,
a curricular framework to
redesign all of the courses
that those teachers would
take, and then we took that,
and that's our professional
development model now.
So it's grounded on the
kind of notion of k'e,
which is a word from the Navajo Nation
which talks about relationships
and then goes into like the cycle
that is a Navajo learning cycle,
which is aligned with the four directions,
which basically is about
reflection, planning,
implementation, and then reflection again,
which is something that has been in place
within our communities
for a very long time,
so doing the work by using
like the different aspects
of what we know to be true.
The second was the
Indigenous Educators Corps,
which is one of AmeriCorps,
which gives, you know, 20-some
young folks, or elders,
the opportunity to be within schools
and to serve alongside educators
in these different schools that we support
and then hopefully becoming
teachers themselves.
But I'd say by being connected,
having the time to do that,
and realizing that there's
not a book or a textbook
you can pick up that's
going to be able to say,
like, "This is how you
like indigenize education."
Eventually maybe somebody will write that.
One of us should probably
do that at some point,
but like working collaboratively
and being able to show what that's like.
And then always having many resources
within the individuals who
were around our students
and families that wanted
to see this happen.
So that's always been helpful, too.
- Great, well, I can talk to you all day,
but we are already at the end of our time.
- Oh, man!
- Thank you so much
for sharing your work.
It is so interesting
and inspiring to hear.
So thank you for all you're doing.
- Well, thank you, and
thanks for this opportunity.
Huge fans of all the work that
you all do in the world, too.
And so I appreciate
this, and I hope you all
have a good rest of your month and day.
- Thank you, and for all those listening,
we do have another show on Thursday
with Pedro De Bruyckere.
He's the author
of "Urban Myths about
Learning and Education"
and "More Urban Myths about
Learning and Education,"
and he will be announcing for
the first time his new book,
so 12:00 PM Pacific, 3:00
Eastern on Thursday to hear more.
Thanks, all, for joining us.
(chimes ringing)